hey guys so we decided to do an ask IG
episode and you guys always yell at me
because I don't actually ever really
answer your questions so I brought along
Jenna to answer some questions with me
so collectively this is going to be a
fantastic ask IG episode oh okay
mandalas okay what's the first question
so pretty shiny sparkly wants to know
what do you think if she surprised to
YouTube stardom and beyond
whoa and beyond who do you think how do
you feel about this whole YouTube thing
well I don't really have an opinion on
it I think I'm oh that's uh well you
know what I like it because I get to
come to see you in LA
oh that's amazing la cabeza de pinna no
I'm thinking move on next question I
still know the beyond means me to like
me being on Vampire Diaries this week
now I'm really proud of her
make sure you watch I'm Simpson he's a
ronin Oh Dan Danny Danny did opened fog
is off bhagavad daddy wants to know what
was it like growing up together i
terrifying really what namche kidding ah
save a bad memory I don't really
remember I don't know her either but
what are we watching home videos crack
tortured me no no I did not
no way I would never would never know
but do you remember when you made three
into a backflip off the couch and she
cut almost seriously injured I do like
that her arms around her back and it was
like you clean yeah this is how I learn
but it wasn't a rule which is I got a
cartwheel without your hands
that's what I was like growing up as
your steam mmm next question has Justine
ever made you so angry that you cried oh
definitely
definitely when we were younger but I
don't remember what about oh I remember
one specific time we were in the kitchen
we got in a fight you did something so I
went up to her and slapped I just
slapped you I know right
then she started chasing me and I got
real scared and ran away I definitely
raised that do you remember that no
laughs - you guys used to beat the crap
out of me but I used to torture you when
you were little but then you guys grew
up and you got taller and stronger than
me and next question stage sarah c SC
yes what's the funniest memory you both
shared and can't remember any but a lot
really how come I can think I can't
either but we laugh a lot we do with off
all the time funny it's never a wait
[Music]
don't think of anything let's come back
to that
I forget okay BAE BAE be some type of
some beb breezy how did you decide you
wanted to start vlogging and what was
your first vlog about well I don't think
you could actually answer I can't know
how do not know ask German yeah I forgot
I mean I have videos the date back to
before vlogging was actually a word I
think mostly I just like to really
document things that happen in my life
because I have a really poor memory love
you can see I was even watching some of
our old videos of like stuff that we did
like a couple summers ago that was a lot
of fun
I guess I live my life in
post-production okay
the exclusive I have you ever done
something to your sister that she never
knew about like a memory game oh I know
did you like poop on my toothbrush or
something I know I think you might
notice but you're real mad
oh I'm breanne I used to actually go in
your room and steal your clothes a big
deal yeah but you never know why don't
you see my clothes my clothes sucked I
don't know guys I read my diary your
diary
Oh guess you didn't thank God I not
equal deal all of your guys's money
question mean obreon cuz she's always
save her money and I would just be like
take that dollar no I don't feel bad for
stealing your clothes I'm actually very
mean I shocked that you're wearing yeah
but that was different
I'm wearing it I asked you it's true
nice question what's the worst thing
she's ever died about guys life I can't
remember anything
we got card game and you gotta put all
the cards and you clip on Carter when
you gotta find a matching cards what
then the man question what's the worst
thing she's ever lied about my god he
what about you still lying high school
of giving blood I did I was always
afraid to give a flood so I used to play
volleyball and to get out of volleyball
practice I like put a bandaid on my arm
and like colored it yellow with a
highlighter and said that I gave blood
so I couldn't run and I bet you regret
that now cuz you don't even know your
blood type I know I got a blood typing
test and I screwed it up as you don't
Amazon and I call Jen I was like dad I'm
scared
oh I messed that thing up so bad I might
be an O Negative
what does this mean let me just call my
mom see if she knows what my blood type
is o neg negative and I call my mom and
she's like it's not possible for you to
be no negative because that must mean
that you're not my child and then they
started freaking out like mom I'm not
yours
techadon because your dad just a comment
hey oh my gosh where did I come from the
thought
dad I'm not yours Jenna we're not
related that's that's how I knew cuz
we're deaf we always like to sing the
same stuff that I know I put your hands
in the air going up I'm gonna stay there
I'm gonna stay there I'm a positive by
the way
okay please have you ever killed anyone
next question
we're just need a tomboy she wasn't a
tomboy no you were going to tell me what
you never really I'm weird he like hid
in her room she wanted our mom to paint
in her room black and my mom was like no
so she banned at navy please there's a
little bit of navy blue steel in my room
and hideous what was your nickname as
what were you oh well right reading is
hard but well what was your nicknames as
kids it should be what were your nicking
okay whatever
okay so what were your nickname is Kinz
yours is when one
it's I still call her one yeah I know I
get tweet one sleepy Alicia when when I
can't remember yours are you Jesse boo
Jesse Keveza I you should have just you
know I mean you guys everyone always
used to call me just and just Jesse put
ah oh yeah oh okay
Martian authors Oh Cody God I have the
sniffles
Cody Norris at 94 words and I won't come
for Cody uh have you ever broken one of
her Apple products are you kidding me if
she ever not broken whatever Apple one
then i shattered my iphone real bad I
might have been an original I don't
really remember I know I was living the
tape just go at the time and here's a
clip from that
[Music]
[Applause]
where did you and Jenna realize your
gambling obsessions oh not an obsession
Oh hobby when was the first time
movement because you know I definitely
know I filmed it it might have been
Thanksgiving her Easter like two years
ago no no I am 21 for two years so oh
yeah ha ha ha I just can dance
[Music]
oh my god in the morning another hood
got some bussiness a bulky 14 have you
ever peed your pants other than when you
were in diapers hey Jenna give her
pooped your pants all of them when you
were in diapers yeah okay okay let's be
fair it was flu season March 2011 that
was those this year yeah last fire last
year flu okay it was just a little poo
oh my god moving on that was rude that
was you almost pooped your pants that
one done a lot of times actually so keep
that D word Adam where you a loser in
high school
no way man look holes chick on block I'm
coming Queen circa 2001 were you
homecoming queen because it was a good
joke oh no she we were nice to everyone
but you
Cabo loser you went to land party okay
okay that's where we draw the line
there's nothing wrong for land boy my
only face two seven one let's know Jenna
interesting more to show you four Disney
movie Beauty gonna be 3d coming up uh
January mailers doesn't matter 30
January 13th because I'll be in Vegas
and I knew that I couldn't go and you
would actually be home yuck try to find
something I go see it with you this is
great oh oh no lime 155 volts no Justine
how was your progress with the pull-up
bar uh well right now it's currently
sitting in the corner of my room and um
I closed the door today because it's the
interest of my bathroom and it fell and
I was going in there like Justine do
what happened we were trying to like
pick up on your door no okay
Dean what are you usually doing when
you're not I J our day hmm
what what huh what are you usually doing
when you're not doing IJ our day gal gal
what's your name gassy ex gizzle that's
awesome dizzle Oh
some of these people probably don't even
know what IJ day is that's where I vlog
every day on i justin's iphone
youtube.com slash I need an iPhone a J
or a day so I'm going through sy j or
other day because i forget our day that
I remember or a day I'm vlogging and so
what are you doing then
I don't know thank all duty way tomorrow
I'm getting sleepy
oh come on alright uh oh my god well we
got ok Damo in 1996 wants to know
oh yes gene how many boyfriends have you
had
well guys while watching there was this
fantastic ask I Jeff sewed ah make sure
you check out Jenna's video on her
channel it's me Jenna II love you guys t
guys in the next episode I see you soon
happy 2012 Miss Mary Mack Mack Mack all
dressed in black black with yellow
buttons no I'm pretty sure they're
silver with damn type with some type of
buttons buttons buttons all down hub
whatever
hi guys love you guys
[Music]